[Music]
better diversity has been a key goal for
the Royal Air Force under its outgoing
chief
a well-intentioned aim but with
unintended consequences after the head
of recruitment quit last year in protest
at an allegedly illegal order to
discriminate against white men
it's a controversy still hanging over
the RAF headquartered here at High
Wycombe with their Chief Marshals sir
Mike wigston preparing to leave office
soon Sky News can reveal new details
about conversations on diversity that
allegedly took place behind the scenes
I've been told by a source that in June
2022 the Air Force's top Personnel
officer in correspondence to staff said
air Chief Marshall wigston was prepared
to bend what's known as the operational
inflow requirement for the RAF out of
shape over the next three years to meet
levels of ambition when it came to
diversity
the air Chief has always insisted his
important drive for more women and
ethnic minorities was never at the
expense of the services warfighting
needs there was no compromise of Entry
standards there was no impact on the the
standard of recruits from any background
there was no impact on the front line or
on operational effectiveness
an Airman sharing his views anonymously
offered a different perspective he said
us on the shop floor so to speak are
struggling we haven't got enough people
to do the jobs and are desperate to have
new recruits new people constantly
Sky News has seen a leaked transcript
from a meeting in June 2020 between the
head of the RAF and the Air Force's
black Asian and minority ethnic Network
it gave a sense of air Chief Marshall
wigston's understandable passion about
lifting the ratio of ethnic minority
recruits in the service from around six
percent to 20 by 2030
if change didn't happen fast enough he
said I'm going to take it as far as I
can in the law right up to the point of
quotas and push positive action to the
limit of the law two years later this
woman grouped Captain Elizabeth Nichol
resigned as head of recruitment after
refusing to implement what she allegedly
deemed to be an illegal order to
prioritize female and ethnic minority
recruits over white men for training
slots an inquiry into what happened has
yet to be published but the defense
secretary said anyone to be found at
fault would be held to account
if someone's broken the law then of
course they will face the consequences
for that like ultimately what what what
people need to understand is that no one
was prevented from joining the RAF as a
result of these conditions an RAF
spokesperson said During the period in
question our selection standards did not
drop and there was no impact on the
operational effectiveness of the RAF
however in hindsight we accept that
despite the best of intentions that some
mistakes were made
the raf's now confident its approach to
recruitment is correct but that slim
comfort for those already impacted
Deborah Haynes Sky News
is in the